this guy slide hey everybody what's
going on Blair welcome to Street cocoa
we got a very special guest from Teen
Wolf Tyler Posey everybody time that's
right that's right hand another his
friend Tyler over here to begin the
price of one that's right of course Beth
is in the chat room Jason O'Malley
creeper in the corner hey today we're
playing some injustice very exciting and
we're playing the wheel of death then
you lose you got to spin the wheel it's
not all bad though there's one get rich
[ __ ] on here and if you can see it very
exciting so maybe Tyler might win some
money absolutely very exciting all right
so let's play dewdrop quiet way ahead
alright alright so this isn't just so
this is basically this is all DC super
okay cool are you are you a comic fan
superhero fan I I am I love it I love it
scorpion he's a downloaded Eric okay
yeah Mortal Kombat combat stuff yeah
dollar be an Oracle I did say that like
my hair is like Joker's - that's right
it looks like it's just been disgusting
and like my own oil looks cool let's go
and go with the Joker if you're gonna go
if we're going hair styles I'm gonna go
you killer frost where do you want to
play where do you wanna play doesn't
matter about the aircraft aircraft we're
in San Diego and there's these there we
go there's these aircraft carriers naval
bases that's right that's right
are you excite your you so you say for
comic-con dude i comic-con is what is
probably my favorite thing that we I get
to do as a member of my TV show that's
awesome TV it's absolutely I think this
is my sixth or seventh year here good
[Applause]
yeah yeah there we go yeah touch a
cookie 1 2 3
yes Shelly she's asking Taco Bell man
[ __ ] what is that Bell man or Shelley
Hennig he's asking if if she's a nice
person she's my can't win my co-stars
and she nicest person ever
oh dude you are really good at this game
I just punched you once I'm not that
good woman
the Joker is really slow that's low he
smells like menacing he's got a knife
though I feel like I'll land my fists oh
[ __ ]
okay so yeah Comic Con I've been here
the cinemas seventh year six or seven
I'm gonna go is seven I don't think it's
been six that's crazy I don't think it's
been seven this 2016 what do you got
playing down here what are you gonna be
doing plan I have the honor of haut
co-hosting the fandom Awards this year
oh that's right well done well done
okay we see by the way this Sunday on
MTV it's well the 12th I'm co-hosting
with my good friend Bella Thorne ólafur
awesome best name in the game yeah just
thinking of that the great name great
name yesterday I was texting her and
born on my phone like she was meant for
this business
yeah that our superhero she could've
been a super fella thorns a great story
yeah so all right so hit these two hit
these two do it do it oh no it's that
full point yet I'm just gonna [ __ ] with
home hit you oh man dude you're winning
man whoa I know there's things breaking
let's gotcha all right there we go
your forehead him now Oh baby oh that's
awesome you miss that's not cool I don't
I don't look I don't want you to let me
it'll go oh don't worry we'll go back up
and then oh yeah dude yeah the crowbar
to the crotch
whoo part of the project exactly CC TT
study just said why so serious
exactly and then I've got my fun stuff
is going on I'm doing a panel for Teen
Wolf oh that's exciting
I've got a bunch of see who these people
like any of these castes I got dylan
o'brien is gonna be here
do a little Brian don't Brian will be
here with us we got Dylan Sprayberry
nice Oh God I'm selling town I'm still a
human body I can actually you know what
it's kind of hot in this room that kind
of that look pretty good all you want
yeah all right yeah so okay now you spin
the wheel all right I spin the wheel
here we go wila dad where you got oh
that's puppy can cut the puppy cam
[Music]
[Applause]
all right copy some of the wheel of
death is Atari sometimes it's a treat
you know to say that would mess it to
Street that was really nice
now it's great all right let's go select
new fighter oh man yeah so we got Dylan
Sprayberry Dylan O'Brien Shelley Hennig
Arden show Holland Roden
yeah and Cody Christian with us that's
awesome they'll be on our panel and and
you are you guys like super secret about
the next season of Teen Wolf okay can
you give any any any little teases
always spices we're always really really
secretive where it were all right we're
in our third episode now I had the
scorpion oh do it I gotta I'm gonna hot
girl man I'm getting some wink in my
wing zone you're all about the wing zone
yeah I know
bring out the bad girls bad girls
talking about getting getting in touch
with your estrogen exactly for people
who don't watch she will bring in three
people up to speed on where we're at
okay cool okay look forward to in the
next season I work on a TV show called
teen on MTV my character Monday nights
at 10:00 they go thank you Monday nights
at 10:00
oh but then he's transported to this
world this is a cool game man I would
spend hours okay so my character is I
have an outcast in school and in life
and we've all been there we've all been
there I've been there right now you're
currently there I'm currently and he
gets bit by a wolf and his life patterns
around and he gets all these beautiful
towers but with great power comes great
responsibility and yeah absolutely
I'm a geek otherwise yeah yeah you are
up to date I'm just this mace thing is
awesome oh and I kind of learned how to
become the leader of my town and my pack
of my friends you're getting confidence
through my confidence bills you know as
the seasons go on but one of the cool
things about this new season season 5 is
that my confidence kind of gets shut
down a little bit and and my character
goes to a really dark place he's usually
not like a plan of action he always
knows where to go he's the leader he was
how to get out of bad situations and
this time he he is like a loss oh that's
great that's kind of cool year are you
would you say your character kind of at
a crossroads almost uh he's gonna or
he's kind of in a don't he's like a
downward spiral I love it cuz he's
definitely been in Crossroads before you
know
which direction to take but this time he
just he's completely at a loss
things are bad things are happening with
his with his pack his friends and he
doesn't know why I love it whoa do you
like I did I distract you by asking you
questions I'm that's a healthy way to do
the two things do the two banks do it do
it oh oh no I used to practice with
scorpion that's actually I got into
acting it says that you we had at Boone
yeah the crater Mortal Kombat yeah who's
he came to clean world common with I
said yeah he did the voice it was
awesome good we had him say all this
stuff like Oh shook the hobo liked it
that's good that's great give me some
more card you actually did the boy yeah
he is the boy with the real voice that's
so cool man all right man I lost again
I'm gonna have to exactly puppy Gary
[Music]
TV's alright alright you know I'm
getting serious that puppy's exhausting
it is it is it takes it out of you it
takes it out of you guys alright let's
see okay so yeah season five season five
is five you know we're in we're into our
third episode now season five is all
about trying to keep our pack together
our pack my pack I'm the leader of my
pack its splinter I am the Alpha like it
yes alpha man gonna be a girl too I'm
all someone with boobs all right I'm
gonna be a woman yeah
oh you know I'll go back girl oh here we
go let's play in the Batcave damn it
let's no jewel it just got some city
Gotham City Bourbon I love it let's do
it
um and so my packs being torn apart I
don't know why I think it's because of
me
those are in later episodes though but
there's just there there's so much stuff
about our show we try to keep it really
really relatable you know aside from the
werewolf stuff cursor characters are
entering our senior year high school
whoa oh yeah yeah yeah so a lot of our
fans are doing that too you know yeah
that's all I really like that that's
really awesome so you know we still try
to keep the scenarios alive and real and
the kids are still teenagers and kids
name and human
despite something werewolf so
this human element arrived that's cool
and it's gotta be awesome to like
because this is one of the like you said
we're the biggest times remove the most
fun times you get to meet a lot of your
fans yeah everyone's so grateful and our
fans are so damn loyal yeah like there's
people waiting in our line yes people
are waiting our panel line for like like
the day before and and I think lastly is
that you are the third biggest entities
so I can one on dead and Game of Thrones
something to nuts you do you get this
might seem like a stupid question to ask
an actor but do you get nervous in front
of giant crowds because when you're
shooting it's not a big Korean out in
front of a huge is definitely different
I've definitely become I think the most
comfortable out of anybody in my cast a
big crowd yeah you might kick my ass
this round I I'm just I'm just that
stuff is my 4chan love that [ __ ] but I
do I do get a little nervous yeah it's
time to core I step out on the stage
have you have you ever done theater I
know you you're like man collateral
damage made man boobies yeah yeah no
acting for me kind of happened really
naturally like when I was a kid my dad
got me into it when I was really young
oh that's cool I never did any training
I never really got involved in it in
high school I was actually like I was a
working actor when I was a kid so I
didn't really want to that's crazy
to do any of it in school you know yeah
that's cool I know wait so I never
really did anything but I thought about
it recently yes I used to I used to go
on stage with my band I used to be a
band I would play oh yeah and your are
you still in disappearing Jamie know
that we broke up no no what happened
what happened we're lost in Costco and
then a great name by the way lost okay I
loved it I said it's such a good time
with that name and then we did some
really cool things you play some great
shows and sold out some shows and
accomplished things I never thought I'd
wonder the band
then it was a lot of my home with my
hometown friends I got really busy today
working on the jingles oh wow cool yeah
that's great I loved it and the band it
just wasn't fun anymore it felt like
work and yeah we needed to take a step
away and take a break so and you already
have a job so why have you that's like
so so right now I really miss it I
really miss music oh you beat me yes I'm
excited for the day we do it spin the
wheel here we go yeah Death Cab Death
came here we go alright
hurry up best death face bet set went
you ready bestseller undercut look right
to the camera that was a great death
face oh my god scream that was a mate
that's a team old death ray
oh my god that's good oh my god we're
playing it what is this controller is
this we used it for clueless gamer never
we play this for close gamer no this is
like something it eats sushi off this is
beautiful I like this pretty isn't it
yeah alright so pick your guy come near
the red alright I wanna be oh my god I
want to be Wonder Woman yeah yeah oh I
got every day I love Wonder Woman was a
girl last time to know was it good
who's a good nemesis for woo what uh I
think she another woman another woman
yeah because then there's no she's yeah
who's everybody like her she's very
witchy she's got a clothes there what do
you guys play you're you playing Wonder
Woman's hometown or just can't would you
push the button outputs the lines me now
Conan if you lose you have to spin the
wheel of death and do something it's on
here I'm in the room with you you don't
have to scream there is so exciti
libraries are around baby skirts the
other thing and we're all in the same
room max Cox says yes love that Irish
guy
look I just got my I got my I met my
bolo of truth just go you're just trying
to punch it there we go these a lot of
these I'm gonna I'm not gonna show any
mercy yeah hurry up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he doesn't play oh my god this is so
erotic
man to Tyler can use the think Tyler use
the two button choose the two buttons Oh
jr. ready ready ready wait what happened
why are we in this special easy special
move on you're kicking his ass super
kick it and he has been cheated a Serie
top telling him what you doing Tony you
can hit these two buttons on him hit
these two pivot on it do it these two
dude this is a battle yeah this is this
isn't even match oh my god not for long
though
I don't like to even become a flock of
birds yeah no it's just that I think
it's a protected species I can't attack
you oh my god dude this is crazy laughs
this is the best fight I've ever had
with anybody
turned out says Conan strategy is
button-mashing and intimidation it's
working gotcha you got to spin the wheel
you all right Oh will you not seem to
have my interests at heart
Oh get rich [ __ ] got a lot of tickets
yeah scratch it off scratch it off okay
grats roll off there all right are you
doing I don't do things for myself
that's how rich I am
other people scratch off my lotto
tickets so but this you've got on camera
play the shirt
there you go scratch up a lot of tickets
what do we get wouldn't we get home on
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wait
nothing
he won nothing Wow he won nothing dude
that was a long build-up cool cat or
Nothing sorry you're rich enough it's
fine doesn't matter I had to go back to
work
oh that was the most that was at a
sensual experience I've had in my life I
am serious and this too is that was
incredible get in here everybody play
injustice gods among are we getting paid
no don't play this alright see you guys
later hey man I'm kind of glad he didn't
win the lotto ticket what if you had won
like $200 I would've been like just ran
away I love it alright I never would
have gotten out the building though here
we go alright let's do it select new
fighter walked up by the way seating I
welcome my dose of data that was a
battle dude I was worried for you there
is his strategy of not knowing what the
hell he was doing the button mashing
doesn't work well all right I'm going
I'm going big guy oh yeah you know let's
play big guys let's do big guys hey guys
here we go
big dudes let's do a holla justice I did
gets ready during that fight there was a
lot of like it's hot in here and there's
like a lot of I don't know I don't know
who's cuz he was sitting next to me and
like I'm really attracted to me does
this sexual between you two maybe you're
both pregnant now you might both yeah I
feel like Tommy man and like jr. and
with Arnold Schwarzenegger no it wasn't
it was that Junior I think what
[Music]
yeah Oh twins twins oh here we go damn
dude my hands Oh gotcha nation oh nice I
feel like this is like WWE yeah now
we're giving now that the sexual heat is
filtering out of the room there's so
many you can't see if there's so many
pheromones in this room right now it's a
mystery
I can taste it miss you in there you
can't see it exactly a shady fridge says
yeah we code it touches you you become
fragrance yeah you might yeah the whole
stream you guys hogging the whole stream
is great yeah
hey Conan let's sometimes likes to come
in and blow off some steam
oh [ __ ]
wait yeah you hit this one you pick
stuff up okay sorry do you like I don't
tell you about the buttons exactly there
yeah wait yeah hit the they hit this
button right by that statue thing oh
wait yeah oh you pick me up oh dude yes
[ __ ] nice oh gee oh why did I tell you
that now you're killing me
oh here we go here we go oh [ __ ] oh do
you think do your thing see Frankenstein
it's like whoa what did that do oh yeah
oh my god oh nice my own headstone Jesus
all right well done well man here we go
you got spin for a spin for me today
you're fine you're fine there we go what
do we got what do we got
yeah is that good rip [ __ ] I think it
was comic-con trivia comic-con tribute
all right hit us with a comic-con twice
yeah yeah let's do it if I get it wrong
I got to spin the wheel again okay all
right
which character was summoned from hell
by not the ocular uh oh which character
yeah why not see what
Oh Hellboy yeah that's Hellboy Mike
McDonald it great that's a great comment
Oh movies awesome really where he's
awesome love those movies all right here
we go
I'm going now I'm going one of my
favorites Martian Manhunter now we're
playing faves is that Mars here we go
Marshall mint this guy oh oh he's a
character Mars mr. Mars somebody pizza I
can smell it it smells delicious
yeah you know what I don't think so I'm
pregnant
we go yeah you're we can play in space
though I'm dealers do it playing space I
love it I love it I think I'm bringing
it man oh let's respond to some of these
Hellboy yeah yeah hello equation
where's Conan claw Z you just misses go
there's miscoded
laws word sounds word exactly if you're
just joining us we got time to close
your Teen Wolf what's up guys he's also
hosts a man TV fandom Awards special on
Sunday remembering that MTV at 8 p.m.
and when's the panel what's your Teen
Wolf Man team or panel as I believe
Friday Friday but it's not the comic-con
schedule
that's right yeah help me out that's
right she's gonna find a way you know I
don't know I thought follow up follow
your boy Tyler at Tyler G Posey on
Twitter and i underscore love underscore
harvey's yeah on instagram what's the
story functional you about that I love
RVs so I grew I was filming a TV show
for years in Toronto Canada when I was a
kid okay and they have a burger chain
called Harvey's and it's a lot like in
and out okay oh look at them and it's a
chain and it's the best it's the best
burger place in the world and when I
last time I had I was 12 and I just went
back with a pilot my boy Tyler over here
just recently and and and it was the
best burger I've ever had and it was
exactly how I remembered it from like 11
years ago yes and then the name they
named a burger after me oh my god really
it's like the way that it works the way
that it works is like you order your
food you order your burger and then it's
like a subway where you get to pick out
your condom oh that's awesome it's
really cool so I told them what
condiments that order welcome how what
kind of to talk about like Eminem's each
off the burgers man sounds Bob that's
right oh I'm a traveler you got it sure
yeah you gotta try well people think dr.
burgers sound gross but just think about
this like you ever had ever had like
peanut butter and chocolate before
something before they came up with that
pop you were like this is crazy peanuts
and chocolate don't mix maybe oh all
right yeah this is the last thing last
one here we go yeah the last wheel make
it good make it good make it good
that's a good spin Oh
dress to impress you pull something out
of the thing something we haven't done
yet that's right he's gonna be a perfect
way to say goodbye on the side of the
head yeah I love it
awesome thanks to Tyler Posey the MTV
fandom word special airs this Sunday at
8:00 on MTV and of course Teen Wolf
every Monday night at 10:00 on MTV font
Twitter entire G Posey Instagram i
underscore love underscore Harvey's
amazing burger team by the way three
candidates stopped by we had talked
about getting M&Ms on burgers and if
you're down here Jenna go check out the
Teen Wolf Teen Wolf panel what is it do
I know I love it awesome tomorrow
tomorrow I love it tomorrow everybody
thank you say bye to the check bye guys
thanks for hanging out with me I got a
little sweaty and thank you second
toilet that's your first exactly thank
you keep the Hat no way I can keep that
keep it keep it totally yeah just to
impress man dressed to impress all right
everybody
so our next guest we're very very
excited to have none other than you know
Chuck you know from the upcoming heroes
reborn come on in
[Applause]
to the judge all right say onto the chat
oh hey hi everybody we're playing that
please up chatter will it twit twitch
chats which twitch attic which Terzi old
twitter roost all right we're gonna play
a little injustice yeah it's super
yoghurts is super yeah playing the we
like deck alright we lit death so I'm
gonna come trivia if you lose you gotta
sip in the wheel identity rich [ __ ]
you get to scratch off a lot of bad
stuff okay
comic-con Trinity if it's about comic
books if you get it wrong in a spin
again right right embarrassing mommy you
got either tells something embarrassing
about yourself or maybe tell an
embarrassing story okay okay it could be
about a friend to when you lose if you
lose I will leave you with a lot of
check it yeah yes it's good okay exactly
who I want to be all right so we got we
downloaded some extra characters yeah
you got your scorpion for more found
that your general Zod's you're
[Music]
absolutely please notice me kappa d
kappa DS what does that say please we're
noticing you guys notice me cassadee max
oh my god Zachary Quinto no you're wrong
Levi exactly whoever he's Bagram you're
gonna be on heroes reborn I am which is
very very exam I would love here so I
can understand your confusion right
we're two xanax that were on both the
part of the heroes exactly I'm going I'm
going green arrow absolutely I mean
little arrow II right now I'm gonna be
Supes
ah super mama hey Zach I love red red
less on let's get it oh yeah that's this
guy here we go alright done let's get in
oh no no wait you hit the wrong button
let's get it started so there's so many
doing these on here look how many
buttons around here this is madness
this is bad let's see you should every
go which one do I need to press them bad
ba ba ba a button yes I'm good Percy but
now they're okay oh here we go
bye and by the way gamer nerd guard is
just being revoked right no not true not
true gamer nerd card is being punched
because we're playing one of the dirty
where do you want to play where do you
want to play no can you random it you we
can I'll just there's my random Arkham
Asylum there we go the perfect grave
there yeah fantastic
here we go you're gonna let this is like
your punches and your kick what's the
sex okay ah this kid this will grab
stuff from the back background and throw
when we get when your meter gets full
which I'll show you we'll hit these and
exactly okay people now hold on oh so is
my block one of the block is just back
it's just black because more coming you
actually have to hit a button for the
block I know that's lame I'm not into
that
Oh button here we go oh no wait
and this might be too too crazy of a
question but favorite superhero you got
a favorite super you can yo ass oh no no
no no no I love like Louie I'm sorry you
love one no I've got a bow and arrow
you've got like every power of Matt yeah
oh look at him what oh yeah oh you're
loving that boo yeah well I gotta get in
close figure out a move I gotta get in
close Oh suck it second I'm getting how
do I shoot my arrows I don't know can't
use an arrow from of you oh my god
and I can't shoot an arrow this way you
can't oh oh good shootin gosh there's a
good idea yeah he's up there cheering it
decide oh come on oh come on get him get
him
someone oh whoa what's happenin Oh what
that is that you're glowing red and he's
got his hunger ravish'd he's got a he
got a heat rash that's the glowing oh no
wait wait no wait wait like press book
he's press book press both these both
looks close
oh yeah Oh Oh socket in the face
that is crazy I just took you nuts I
just took you into orbit that's amazing
how are you still alive
I'm just getting right back up just a
scratch I'm not having this here we go
Jeep met Jeet mega tank I love you guys
all right there we go
Oh like an arrow can hurt the Man of
Steel yeah exactly
kryptonite Eric it on kryptonite arrow
Superman wins son you ever like a
finishing move is it like a no that's it
you put in videos are you going you
listen for help you're such a good guy
looks like well I'm done kicking your
ass to do ready what is that weighs me
I'm like hell I'm sorry I just beat you
up that's my man all right here we go
wheel of death spin it up spin it up
spin what do we got dressed to impress
all right pull something out of the box
I gotta wear something dumb do you think
so you have been this how many Comic
Cons of you have you been at this is no
no no this is nine so I can never come
to comic-con in 2000 oh you don't have
to wear the shades and no I what I like
it all right I fare type you gotta wear
something I guess I'll be I get to wear
something kind of cool we get to where
we need to take this $10.99 highway
robbery yeah yeah be it someone more
powerful that's ridiculous not be Takata
throw-in Jarrow know what to do yeah
that's probably fair I'm a friend I'm
being cyborg man he's got like a robot
arm is killing it let's play table and
let's do it let's do it let's do it they
need to see oh yeah by the way you can't
sue me
this is not Superman I just want that to
point that up yeah that's it's Superman
is the French bar in super Hey
look at you looking at ya oh you know
what me okay and I'm playing a half
robot guy was it smart with there's
water everywhere yeah baby it's like
some dude oh I'm super slow oh my god
you're killing me yeah dude
oh come on wait to sacked us a little
note like about yours report it starts
September 24th its
Spiros reborns coming out yep and you're
playing I hear you play a very dark and
gritty goblet very dark and dirty so
dark and so gritty um yes that's gonna
be in the second shoots rescue I need to
pay more attention
oh my god dude I hate that slowdown
thing yeah no stop please got a blue
collar
oh right in the dick bar you totally
worried those into cries the dick
shocker yes so Luke Collins and and I'm
married to Joanne Collins played by Judy
Chu county and basically this thing
happens on our son oh come on
yes killing me right now
so our son dies in this kind of bad
incident and it drives us and there's
this before the show starts yes I woke
up I got a year after this thing happens
got it got it
and yeah suck that son all over it ready
get ready yes Oh pull out the big guns
oh yeah that's just like high-powered
Taylor Swift music
weaponize T Taylor Swift I'm about it
yeah don't we just kind of go on this
killing rampage just oh yeah evil
abilities are to blame for our son dying
ooh I love it
that's awesome yeah Jesus yeah now
you're gonna get some of that all up in
your face no way this is gonna be good
Oh smack that's a wind-up
smack again oh man this dry reeseman
then we would
oh my god this is rough at least I had a
chance of Tyler what do we got well you
should know where you get all the puppy
camp here we go you and Bobby come on
the camp
puppy puppies puppies puppies puppies
puppies puppies puppies puppies puppies
all right puppy can we did it that's a
great thing yeah sometimes you get to
see the puppies that's a great um that's
on that's exciting
are you excited to play this kind of
darker dude I am man you because you
know I'm Chuck like I love playing Chuck
and he gets such a great heart bossy you
know it's really wanted to get into
something that was just like what
explore things as an actor I also
challenge other people's perception of
what you do because otherwise people
would just be like oh you do that Chuck
finger yeah yeah one of the things
exactly a lot of it like I can make mac
and cheese yeah you can kick my ass at
this game over and over and over is over
okay yeah exactly
I don't want to be now I'm going Lancer
I love it I love it thank you I mean
lantern you're a huge turn you got to be
excited about Comic Con just as a fan oh
very much so yeah Comic Con is awesome
getting good too now come down for nine
years
no I guess it's been twenty nine twenty
you becoming for a hundred and nine
years that's like 300 years old
which you're oh he's immortal people
don't know this about this there's a lot
of prune juice you moist America bathing
oh come on interview I'll and you're too
nice but yeah but this is the fifth year
we've been doing nerd HQ which is my bet
denim here yeah and go to the nerd
machine go to the new machine okay I'm
gonna you can like all my panels or
livestream on
that's awesome you guys got a great a
podcast habit with you yeah got some
green lantern e100 that was it he got
heads that was oh missiles I'm getting
myself I don't want to get too close to
you I feel like I'm gonna that radiation
can't be good for me it's like you've
been holding a cell phone here you for
too long or something like why are you
[Music]
boom seconds yeah you have a great you
guys have a great podcast on on the nerd
mean by Clare grant oh yeah who's
awesome yeah brother
Blair just was on this the other day
she's the bomb yeah it's us cuz there's
four of us that are all kind of hosted
so no that's like rainin title of a
[ __ ] off off and out of town
Tyler is mad busy that guy is words it
Rick James or somebody else is really
dizzy missile special I missed you here
we go miss you though
oh man suck you in the money power how
you and then smash it with buses I love
that song it's a great hit
put a piece of that lie put a beat to
that please do so nope get this guy okay
look at it how about you stop what do
when you're not saying I see I seriously
I'm trying this is ridiculous and
embarrassing
missile huh dude dude I can't you really
nice you should be practicing more I
love Mira like yes this letter I'd [ __ ]
you not it's the first time I've ever
played this game
it's rigged this really is the first
time yeah my ass
alright here we go you'll adapt against
dangerous
oh the tag back that means you spin
oh good tag that guy oh here we go
letter Oh what do we got what do we got
come on come you can't catch it yeah
alright here we go got you there yeah we
just was that pop-up video I wanna do
this one of the like it's it's a ditty
that's been in my head ever since that
shows on being a Sunday and I okay all
the time so catch well nearly I never
see you in casual dress no you've never
seen it's you're weird in the suits are
we doing
pick your guy you're red again Cody
you're ready red alright and I will be
is that a woman magician yeah Santa is
into the magic okay again I like it when
women fight women should be Batgirl you
can't be Wonder Woman because I've
already been hurt there's a village
should absolutely be able to be nice
here we go let's play let's play
whoo I do love the fortress of solitude
Superman San Diego there's no break
fortress of solitude Jack is really good
and I gonna die trying
Mikey beat Tyler Posey so I don't know
we'll see who's gonna win you be Tyler
yeah you love it
laying yells a lot yeah I'm very loud
she's so excited I'm just so excited
yeah telling you that there's a lot of
female crunching going on in this place
oh I'm here for that I told you he's
good and better than always think you
get her a man who's in his late sixties
hey what did Wonder Woman get a sword
she never had a sword a sword she wants
what happened okay just show a lot yeah
I'm telling you exactly like totally
just hit you in the face
yeah but oh no what happened I don't
know
[Applause]
[Music]
look John I'd let that pervy robot in
the background it's just watching oh
come on it was my super I want my super
you're not full except full super wonder
what we do in the wheel cut it's like
Charles blow that's gonna get rich [ __ ]
yeah everyone I need more money more
money here we go he's great but I'm
doing my man scratches by let up again
for me you have to admit that was very
close
wait a minute uh-uh that was not close
at all how bad I feel at an entire I
don't think you took me down once and I
had almost a full power
that was insane look at these guys okay
me he's living out in the bathroom
what a creep you know what here's my
complaints with the game yes Wonder
Woman never had a sore I can't just bad
things I say she's from oh yeah wasn't
it no what is it was it like it Amazonas
yeah no she was and she had like a it's
like a whole tribe of like bow almost
Amazon women who I know woman's from an
island
she's from an island but she want your
boat right oh you're violent on earth a
secret island she was okay but she was
still part of this kick-ass tribe of
women who were like Amazon is's that's
also key then they had to see books she
never had a sword so it's like oh I
picked Batman and guess what he's got a
38 revolver
he's shooting people in the abdomen
that's not like so I love but I do love
these controllers because they hide when
I don't see magic back to work you not
only defeated me but did so while
wearing your sunglasses which is
incredibly it's it's intimidating okay
so the injury code
and I said the inverse inverse of what I
needed do say goodbye to everybody the
check hi everybody in the chat agree
with me Wonder Woman never had and never
should have a sword was reckless he's
wrong he's right he's wrong fight it out
[Music]
he got the lot of a terrible loser yeah
well I don't take it twice in a row for
currencies unfair
I was Hawaii really got that yeah he got
the letter together for yeah yeah we
didn't win any money which is good
it's never landed on the bank of history
yet well look this somebody said by
strange person
yeah that's pretty what history oh you
can't tell but there's a musk that Conan
brings in here it smells like Erebus
cheese my nervous journey this is how he
describes it that's right Harley Quinn
I'm Harley Quinn where you want to play
we're gonna write be whatever with that
trick Margot Robbie this doesn't matter
where we play a lot of my ability to
capture a sting somebody's getting a
little cocky give him the old I don't
know after it feels fair sunglass
oh [ __ ] exploding baking the crust come
on this is crazy
alright alright stick your head in there
I'll eat it stick your hand in there and
I'll eat it this just sounds wrong that
seems funny said oh my god oh that's
tasty
the honey bun and we haven't seen a
honey bun time honey one time oh man
you know what this is gonna mess up my
controls all sticky I mean I got time to
kick your ass with one here we go last
bad one more time everything comes down
to this wow I could really use some
water bag of mystery all right I'm going
Lex Luthor look at that suit look at
that suit you know what I will go
doomsday there we go dear mr. dome hey
let's play Metropolis you know that's
that's fitting that's fitting Lex in
doomsday that's right fighting for
Superman's on and then battling it out
against him but for him battling it out
yeah if you could have any superpower
what would it be any superpower
I think teleportation oh that's a good
one because flight would be awesome exam
if you really want to travel anywhere
you got to bring your bag with you and
it's probably cold you're fine job back
yeah you're gonna wear yeah altitude you
know altitude yeah what do you think
about teleportation you just boom you're
there but wouldn't you be afraid of
teleporting into something you know the
battle by the way these are too big dude
I love it so yeah if you want it so like
if you're near that thing up there and
you're hit and you hit this button
you'll you'll throw it up notice how I
didn't stop down you know huh yeah
whatever yeah whatever
do something Lex there we go
attaboy
that's true Oh little fire scare me cow
look at the end of us here we go baby
because I'm not really sure where we go
can I get it
flex come on boy your boy Lex nice any
other triggers you got it
sorry the triggers yeah a deist user do
it do it these two no don't help alright
get up get him oh good one yep they did
nothing perfect just like I planned
just basically do calisthenics uh oh yes
my - I need to get you are we doing
something you got some of your throat
there what you said who is that
Schwarzenegger you all read now stop it
stop it
ah come on gimme I'll take a bag of
combos here we go here we go oh I love
that ass why can't I just have that ax
man stop hitting me oh now we stop I'll
stop hitting me oh man it's still true
oh my god dude I can't lose again I
can't oh alright before we say goodbye
one last bit of them we actually here
you want to spend a minute you spin it
what is it
puppy cam cam show the puppies oh the
puppies show the puppies that will do it
for today thank you so much
Zachary Levi
heroes reborn premieres September 24th
on NBC and follow this guy at Zachary
Levi on Twitter and Instagram and go to
the nerd machine comm or offer all your
delicious
nerdily needs that's all correct that's
all right there we go exactly like this
guy and it just nice to meet you oh my
god thank you guys for joining us my
stream Coco we will see you tomorrow
right back here
same bat-time same bat-channel at noon
pacific time and please check out kona
tonight at 11:00 on TBS it's our first
show from comic-con
awesome see you guys tomorrow peace out